I can't imagine doing e-mail without GMail.
I can't imagine collaborating on a presentation
or on a design document by mailing around
versions of content back and forth between
people and saying, "Who's got the latest one,
who's got what edit?"
And I can't imagine being tethered to one
particular physical device to find my data
and my application.
It would make no sense anymore.
We all know that.
Companies know that.
Every company we talk to is trying to figure
out how can I shift my weight to the cloud?
How can I use the Web more heavily with the
applications that I use and the applications
that I build at work?
The problem is, it's still hard to do that.
It's still too hard to take advantage of the
Web at work.
It's hard for a few reasons.
First, it's hard because it takes too long.
From the time you have a great idea or your
boss has a great idea or the VP of marketing
has a great request, from the time you have
the great idea and you want to create a great
application, new technology, new tools, takes
too long to turn that idea into reality.
The second thing that's hard is, we don't
stand in one place anymore.
That application that you're running, you
might need to access it from the back of a
taxicab.
Some of your users need to access it from
an airport or from the lobby of their hotel.
Because people are working everywhere, they're
working all the time, the applications that
you build for them need to run on all the
devices that people are using.
The third thing that's hard today is, architectures
tend to trap people so that the choice you
make in what tool stack do I use, how am I
building my application, that choice you make
today locks you in to a deployment model for
tomorrow that you may not be ready to lock
yourself into.
And then, finally, if any of you have the
job that this guy has, you look at this slide
and probably say, he's only got a half dozen
applications he's taking care of for his company.
The CIOs that we talk to tell us that they
usually have on the order of a thousand applications
that they're trying to manage to run their
business.
And they need better tools to be able to manage
all those applications.
Over the next 40 minutes, we're going to show
you what we've done, working with other people,
to enable fast and familiar development using
tools and languages you already know to crank
out great Web applications.
We're going to show you how to make those
applications mobile-ready so they can run
and reach your users wherever your users are.
We're going to show you an architecture used
-- based on open standards that give you
flexible deployment so you have portability.
You can choose how you want to build your
apps and you can choose where you want to
deploy your apps separately.
And, finally, we'll show you some new tools
that give you the ability to manage the hundreds
and thousands of apps that are being built
to run businesses in the cloud.
Now, as we set out to do this, it was very
important that we did this staying true to
the principles and values of the Web.
The principles and values that you've heard
all morning about how open standards lead
to interoperability and portability, which
leads to choice, and choice is what drives
innovation.
We looked for who can we work with, who can
we collaborate with that shares those values,
that understands the importance of standards
enabling innovation, and that has spent years
understanding how to help enterprise developers
build great apps at work.
And I'm very happy to announce that we've
been working closely with VMWare to enable
exactly that, building on our complementary
strengths to enable open standards to lead
to great innovation in the enterprise.
I'd like to welcome to the Google I/O stage
Paul Maritz, the president and CEO of VMWare,
to tell you a little bit about what we've
been doing together.
[ Applause ]
>>Paul Maritz: Good morning.
It's a great pleasure to be with you here
today.
Most of you will know VMWare in terms of the
work that we've been doing in allowing existing
applications to be iterated forward and take
advantage of a cloud-oriented way of doing
computing.
Customers have huge investments in large bodies
of existing applications that they can't walk
away from, and just about the only hope for
these applications is through virtualization,
which allows you to kind of encapsulate these
applications, jack them up, put them in a
black box, slide new functionality underneath
them and eventually start sliding the applications
themselves around.
So we've been doing a lot of work in this
world of existing applications, allowing customers
and companies to become more cloud-like in
their internal operations and actually allow
them to start extending their data centers
outside of their own physical premises, into
infrastructure that they can rent from external
service providers.
And this is all well and good.
It's very important work to be doing.
But the question really becomes, what about
new applications?
And it's clear that there are going to be
many clouds out there.
Customers are going to build their clouds
internally.
Service providers are going to build clouds,
very large companies like Google are going
to build clouds.
And wouldn't it be great if we could have
a way of writing applications that on the
one hand can take full advantage of a particular
cloud, but also be portable across clouds.
If you think of these infrastructure-level
clouds as kind of the new hardware, what is
the new operating system for the cloud?
What is that layer of abstraction that's going
to allow us to write applications that can
look great on a variety of clouds?
And it's our premise, as it is Google's, that
the new operating system is these extended
frameworks.
And as you well know, developers over the
last several years have by and large voted
with their feet, and traditionally -- and
now work within frameworks that give them
much higher levels of productivity.
And that's the reason last year we at VMWare
acquired what we think is one of the best
of breed new-generation frameworks, the Spring
framework.
This comes from work that was started 2002
by Rod Johnson and others, who founded Spring,
who had been working in the Java world and
had come to the conclusion it was just too
hard to write Java in EJB applications.
And they evolved the Spring framework, which
is oriented around a very simple, lightweight,
but extremely powerful object model.
What the result is is that more than half
of the lines of new Java code being written
today are written in the context of the Spring
framework.
They started that effort based on open source.
And they have continued in the open and open
source tradition.
And we're committed to continuing that.
And so late last year, we started in-depth
conversations with Google and said, wouldn't
it be great to give the world's largest body
of developers, the Java community, a way of
writing really efficient, great cloud-based
applications?
And as a result, we have been working with
Google to bring to bear what we know about
writing the back-end of great, high-performance,
portable applications, with what Google has
developed around the front-end.
A perfect marriage is to bring these two technologies
together and give the industry an open and
open source layer to cloak the clouds, to
allow you to get the fullest benefit from
your investments.
The one thing I have learned over the years
is, the more choice you give developers, the
more promise you give to developers, that
they're going to be able to get a return on
their investment by having the widest possible
number of places that they can deploy this
technology, the greater the motivation, the
greater the applications that result.
So we have had our two teams working together
to really integrate the Spring framework and
the Google Web Toolkit, and now give a complete
answer as to how to write an end-to-end application,
the back-end and the front-end, in a way that
you can deliver really great, exciting apps
that work across clouds, across devices, with
a deep commitment to doing this in an open
and open source fashion.
So with that, I'm very happy to let you see
some of the results of this work.
>>David Glazer: Thanks.
[ Applause ]
>>David Glazer: Thank you, Paul.
I've been very excited to work with Paul.
I've been even more excited to have our engineers
and Paul's engineers working together to deliver
on exactly what he said.
The first of the promises that we made is
that over the next 40 minutes, we're going
to show you how we can use familiar tools
to enable fast development.
And the way we've done that is, we have -- exactly
as Paul said -- integrated the Spring back-end
development tools, which let Java developers
build great back-ends to their apps, with
the Google Toolkit front-end.
So you get the power of HTML5 in a complete
Java stack, back-end and front-end, integrated
together.
To show you how that works, I'd like to bring
up Ben Alex, who's the lead engineer for Spring
Roo, and Bruce Johnson, who is the lead of
the Google web Toolkit team to give you a
demo of how do these tools work together,
which you will be able to try yourself after
the keynote.
[ Applause ]
>>> Thank you, David.
If you've used Google Web Toolkit before,
you know GWT makes it easy to build rich Web
applications completely in Java.
Not only the server-side code, which you have
always been able to right in Java, but also
the client side, the Ajax code that runs in
the browser.